Trying every workout in Chicago so you don't have to,
and today we are taking 1bar class at Equinox.
This is obviously a bit different of a review
because to take a class at Equinox
you have to be an Equinox member,
but for me what makes my membership so worth it
is having the flexibility to work out of my own
or take one of their classes.
I've tried their classes,
specifically their bar class,
at all the different studios,
and I find that they're all pretty similar.
A lot of the trainers do teach at multiple studios.
I'm like the biggest bar class fan ever.
I got really into it in college
and so this is one of my favorites to go to at Equinox,
but there's literally so many options.
For me, the best part of the bar classes at Equinox
is that it's a really good mix of off the bar work
and then on the bar work.
And they're also pretty high intensity.
The music's great,
the instructors are encouraging,
and so you'll definitely still get your heart rate up.
Watching myself back doing this workout
is extremely humbling.
But anyways,
the studio space is great. I will say
if you go to some of their more popular class times,
it does get a little crowded,
but I kind of like that
they also have unheated and heated class options.
So this was a heated bar class,
and I'm a sucker for a heated class.
And the best part of any Equinox
class is grabbing a cold towel at the end.
Definitely will be trying more of Equinox classes
considering I'm locked into my membership for a year,
so stay tuned!